it'd be like you think a [ __ ] genuine
you think by listening to somebody music
it give you like a picture like thing i
think of this person like this and i
think this person like i hold him up
here because he'll be on that man you
meet these [ __ ] man they be
like
who the [ __ ] write [ __ ] music you
feeling like you're the same person bro
like right it should be weird and they
were like i didn't help a lot of people
because i'm one of them people and i
still do i don't let that [ __ ] change me
i helped like when i had my run even
though like people used to tell me like
bro you shouldn't do this feature with
this person you shouldn't do this
feature with this person they ain't they
they just trying to use you i'm like bro
if i [ __ ] with somebody music i'm gonna
do it because
i'm not doing this [ __ ] for the money or
right i'm not doing this [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm just having fun that's
what i like to do yeah i like this [ __ ]
i'm going to do it you feel me so i gave
millions of features away i mean some
people would say arguably you probably
give away your biggest hooks to other
artists i literally one of those people
that like because at the time like my
lady wasn't really doing what i wanted
to do for my music and [ __ ] like they
was putting [ __ ] out but it wasn't like
having like a big push so if i come
across somebody that i know like they
label going hard for them right now
they're gonna probably i will give you a
whole like some [ __ ] that i already got
right and just give it to you
let's keep me on it you feel me